it's a basic human need
[Music]
a roof over our heads
but in cities all over the world right
now it can't be taken for granted people
don't have homes right now people don't
have anywhere to go right
now for the next decade we will still
see this problem the world's housing
market is hurting we're living in a time
of rapidly rising rent tired out tenants
developers drowning in debt and house
prices higher than ever before and
barely a corner of the globe
is untouched in this video we'll tour
some of the housing crisis hot spots
every time you think it's
it's not possible it just continues to
move higher i think homelessness will
will rise in a lot of these urban areas
so what are we doing to take on these
problems find out in business beyond
so let's start right here in berlin
because in recent years tenants in the
german capital have been making an awful
lot of noise
they've regularly railed against rents
that have risen 42 over the past five
years they claim greedy landlords
private equity firms and hedge funds
have made the city unaffordable to many
who've traditionally lived here in early
2020 they scored a major victory the
world watched on amazed as the left-wing
government in berlin introduced a cap on
rents and froze them for five years for
tenants it seemed too good to be true
and it turned out it was a little over a
year later a federal court ruled the law
unconstitutional rendering it null and
void
many tenants still feel crushed under
the heel of the powerful landlords who
own their apartments we were invited
into the temporary home of heinz jurgen
quarter he was moved into there after
the discovery of mold in his original
apartment the landlord said repairs
would take a matter of weeks three years
later he still can't return to his flat
valve
jurgens have led berliners to demand
that power is taken out of the hands of
major landlords in a referendum in
september of 2021 they voted in favor of
a law that would force major property
owners in the city to hand some of that
property back to the city authorities
it followed a colorful campaign
demanding the confiscation or
expropriation of apartments from
berlin's biggest landlords
under
[Music]
a whole host of political and legal
hurdles need to be overcome if those
expropriations are ever to actually
happen but the result of the referendum
along with policies like that
short-lived rent cap mean that large
property developers might want to think
twice before investing their money in
the german capital
property prices may be climbing in
berlin but around 9 000 kilometers away
they're living in a completely different
world berlin isn't even the most
expensive place to live in germany but
hong kong consistently tops lists of the
world's least affordable cities over the
last two decades housing crisis has been
expanded for
two times three times for some of the
estate maybe four times in hong kong
the sars epidemic of 2003 and 2004 is
the opening chapter of the hong kong
property price story since the downturn
the disease brought the island's economy
has been going from strength to strength
only interrupted by the arrival of
another more recent coronavirus
that period has also seen many people
from mainland china taking advantage of
a policy allowing them to move to hong
kong
this policy has been gradually
increasing the residential population in
hong kong and at the same time hong
kong's economy is picking up and we also
have so many expat population that comes
in
and so over the last 20 years i would
say that it has been like a structural
shortage in terms of this kind of
housing supply here the average cost of
a residential property in hong kong is
thought to be over 20 times the average
household income in the territory it had
been thought that protests in recent
years and the increasing influence of
beijing in hong kong might take the heat
out of the market
but there's been little sign of that
once again property prices are heading
for record highs the government
acknowledged the issue and they're
trying to look into various ways to
solve it but i'll say it would take
quite some time to change the whole game
if not the next decade hong kong's
housing market is also feeling the side
effects of developments on the chinese
mainland
the city of shenzhen has become a
sprawling tech hub with a population of
13 million people and property prices
there are also soaring
so much so that border districts of hong
kong are being seen as a future
more affordable commuter area for the
giant metropolis
now while we're talking about china we
have to mention evergrand the debt
crisis at the country's biggest property
developer shocked markets around the
world it left hundreds of thousands of
people unsure if they would ever live in
the homes they'd forked out all their
savings to buy
and has called into question the very
foundations of china's property market
chinese and hong kong investors seeking
to invest elsewhere are often turning to
our next stop the canadian city of
vancouver
property prices are moving further and
further out of reach for the people who
live there
if you're a nurse or a school teacher
here or
you know even even some lawyers and
doctors and stuff that you know housing
is is very expensive uh and in some
professions you know completely
unaffordable in september of 2020 the
average home in metropolitan vancouver
would already have cost you over a
million canadian dollars around 850 000
us dollars but in the 12 months after
that that price went up by 130 000
canadian dollars that's a 13 rise in one
year but vancouver is no stranger to
such risers
why the huge driver is ultimately uh you
know really cheap low borrowing costs i
mean today in vancouver right you can go
and borrow a variable rate mortgage for
one and a half percent you know we've
got inflation running at four percent so
you know a real negative interest rate
of two and a half percent we have a lot
more investors funneling into the
housing market just be on that basis
property prices have become one of the
big political issues in canada in
elections in september parties across
the political spectrum ran on promises
to tackle soaring house prices
prime minister justin trudeau was
re-elected partly on a pledge to ban
foreigner home purchasers for two years
but vancouver already has a hefty 20 tax
for buyers from overseas
a lot of the foreign owners are really
they're offshore
you know individuals that already have a
canadian citizenship or they have
permanent residency here uh or they have
family that has you know citizenship
here and so they're not really captured
by the tax across the province of bc
foreign buyers made up just over one
percent of all transactions which is a
tiny tiny amount the rise of house
prices in vancouver in recent years
raises a question
when will it stop
surely it can't go on forever it doesn't
feel sustainable
um but it just continues to move higher
when prices have gone up for 30 years
and you can borrow at two percent um
you're going to continue to get this
overwhelming demand that developers just
aren't able to keep up with and
yeah so yeah it's a tough one i just
don't know how it all plays out
while canadians grapple with whether or
not they've got a property bubble on
their hands their neighbors are worrying
about an altogether different imminent
threat
across the border in the united states
hundreds of thousands of americans are
facing the prospect of losing their
homes particularly tenants in places
like new york as state and government
moratoriums on evictions introduced
during the pandemic come to an end
after all americans working in the
sectors where people were suddenly
losing their jobs like retail and
hospitality were far more likely to be
renting than owning their homes
millions of americans have the prospect
of eviction hanging over them in each of
these states over 18 percent of renters
failed to pay their rent on time in
august 2021
in many more states that was still the
case for 10 to 18 percent of tenants
only a few remaining states had a lower
rent delinquency rate
recruit is the strongest i've ever seen
it in history you know so
that makes it very very difficult for
people you know that are kind of living
on the edge so if they're paying
you know
650 bucks a month you know for rent and
that's going up 10 15 20 their incomes
certainly aren't going up 10 15 20
percent so how in a wealthy developed
nation like the united states are so
many people on the verge of being thrown
out onto the street especially when the
federal and state governments have made
available more than enough money to bail
every single one of them out the us
federal government has appropriated uh
almost 50 billion dollars to help
renters with back rent utility payments
uh late fees that kind of thing
and by my calculation uh there are
probably uh
uh about 20 billion dollars 25 billion
dollars in
uh current or marriages so there's
plenty of money
it's just getting that money into the
right hands
one of the barriers to getting the money
quickly is the need to prove that you
lost your job because of the pandemic
marx andy is confident the majority of
people will manage to get the money they
need in time but others are still likely
to fall through the cracks
in a kind of a typical year uh you get
about a million rental evictions so
we'll probably get you know 800k
over the next six months so it'll be a
bit elevated we're going to see it and
it's going to be in certain parts of the
country not everywhere it's not a
problem you know from coast to coast
it's a problem in big urban centers
next we're crossing the atlantic to
dublin where tenants are protecting
themselves by putting up a united front
it is a lot harder for a landlord to
ignore calls from
1300 members across ireland we will
make your life difficult for one for a
better phrase like other cities we've
already looked at dublin's housing
market is red hot but for a unique set
of reasons in dublin a big problem we've
had is lots of developments going up
that are
exclusively built to rent
at a very high profit margin
um looking to cram as much
spaces
into a single building as they can
and then charging premium
ireland's low corporation tax in
comparison with its eu neighbours has
also attracted global tech firms to set
up shop there bringing skilled workers
with the means to pay higher rents
despite attempts to control them for
over a decade now rents across ireland
have been rising and rising but those
risers have been far outstripped by
rents in the capital a place in dublin
city centre will now cost you well over
double what it would have in 2010.
as a result tenants organizations like
cartoon have formed to give individual
tenants the power of the collective they
work like a trade union but for renters
and they've shown they're willing to go
to extreme lengths to protect their
members even blocking evictions while
they're happening
a gentleman had his door drilled in
in the early hours of the morning and a
group of heavies through his entire life
out on the streets a rather intense
standoff with their heavies led to us
essentially shoving them back out of his
house and eventually forcing the
landlord to come down and negotiate with
him and he got to stay in that house
until he now is in more secure housing
but the eviction
was not pushed through the solution to
dublin's problems activists say is
simple build more homes and that is what
the irish government is planning 33 000
of them every year through to 2030 it
should make a major difference
people don't have homes right now people
don't have anywhere to go right now
people are trapped in renting right
now this problem isn't going away this
problem will be worse in 10 years than
it is now
so far we've talked a lot about housing
shortages but building too many houses
can also lead to its own problems the
citizens in our next stop will tell you
in a sense tokyo's housing market is a
story of success despite being a major
city it's remained all but immune to the
high house prices and rising rents that
we've seen in other cities
why
because there are plenty of places to
live
japan has consistently built the best
part of a million new places to live
each year for the past decade the vast
majority of them in cities like tokyo
supply is far outstripping demand in a
country where the population is actually
shrinking
in other words japan has too many homes
and the phenomenon of young japanese
moving out of the countryside to seek
the excitement of the city is resulting
in a real problem
outside of its cities japan is becoming
riddled with abandoned houses many of
them left to rot by owners for whom the
costs and admin associated with keeping
them outweigh any benefits from
maintaining them some researchers say
abandoned homes could account for as
much as 30 percent of the country's
housing stock by 2038. that's a super
abundance of empty houses that many
countries could only dream of
[Music]
and so ends our tour around the world's
troubled housing markets you see a roof
over your head really isn't something
you can take for granted and a global
housing market built
on shaky foundations is one we need to
keep an eye on and that's all from this
edition of business beyond thanks a lot
for watching if you want to know more
about the money that makes the world go
around be sure to check out the business
beyond playlist oh while you're here why
not hit like and subscribe until next
time
take
[Music]